تركيا التي تمكنت من اقتحام عالم صناعه
السلاح مؤخرا هذا بحكم موقعها الجغرافي
وما تمتلكه من شركات حكوميه وخاصه نافذه
في هذا المجال باتت تسع مؤخرا الى تعزيز
دفاعاتها البحريه بصناعه محليه هذا بعد
تجربه ناجحه على منظومه دفاعا بحريه
منظومه بارباروس هذه المنظومه التي تصنعها
شركه روكيت سان التركيه تتكون من رادار
ومنظمته قياده وسيطره وتعقب للاهداف
وتوجيه للنيران ذاتيه الحركه وكذلك
بطاريات صواريخ متنقله كما سيتم دمج هذه
المنظومه مع نظام ادفانتا لاداره المعارك
لتحديد نوع الهدف والصاروخ المناسب للتصدي
له المنظومه لديها القدره على اطلاق نوعين
من الصواريخ الاول من طراز شاكر المضاد
للسفن هذا الصاروخ يصل مداح حتى 150 كيلو
مترا مع راس حربيه
وحتى 70 كجم اما الثاني فهو من طراز كارا
التانجا المضاد للسفن او الاهداف البريه
والذي يصل مداح حتى 2008 كلم مع راس حربيه
يزنوا ماتين 250 كلغم